um yeah so this is going to be a series
of lectures connected to some of the
other lectures you've seen but it'll
take things in kind of a different tack
like I'm going to try to survey a lot of
different topics different results that
have been proved sort of stalking lower
bounds and algorithms in a in a sense
I'll start with the algorithm side so
that's what this lecture is about too
because it seems like that's the the
part we understand best algorithms okay
so I'd like to start with a conventional
view of albums and complexity as I have
seen it and was taught so I was taught
there are two kinds of people there are
algorithm designers and their complexity
theorists and the algorithm designer is
asked you know positive things would
make some problems easy to solve
when can I find an efficient algorithm
and the complexity theorists ask
negative things
what makes other problems difficult when
can we prove the problem isn't easy when
can we prove a lower bound the resources
needed to solve a problem so stated that
way the tasks of the album designer and
the complexity theorist appear to be
inherently opposite one is trying to
find an algorithm when it's trying to
rule it out and furthermore it's
generally believed that lower bounds are
harder than album design and the
intuition there is pretty strong it's in
algorithm design we only have to find a
single nice algorithm that solves the
problem well yeah for whatever a notion
of well then we might come up with
whereas in lower bounds we somehow have
to reason about all possible algorithms
and argue that none of them work well
okay somehow we have to reason about our
ones we will never even see and our you
know them to work work well well Russell
sort of hinted at the kind of false
difference between these two the my
intuition about these things
so in worst case our InDesign for
example yes we only have to find a
single algorithm that works well but it
needs to work on all possible inputs
including ones we will never see ok and
so this is and miraculously we can do
this ok for like many many many many
many problems so maybe we should not be
so intimidated about reasoning about all
possible algorithms provided we set
things up in the right way and so a lot
of these lectures are gonna try to think
about how we set things up in the right
way so we can reason algorithmically
about lower bounds but this belief is
strongly reflected in the literature
just you know look at the relative sizes
of soda and CCC and that's sort of a
high order bit of like you know albums
you know hundreds of albums papers each
year and very few lower balance papers
including in CCC okay alright so what I
want to promote in these lectures and
what other lecturers are doing is
promoting what I call a duality between
circuit analysis algorithms or as we
also call the meta algorithms and
circuit lower bounds now I put duality
in quotes because it's not entirely
formal sometimes you can make it formal
what you meet other times we only have
connections in one direction or we kind
of have intuitions like we can match up
quantifiers like we can match up the
quantifier of the circuit quantifier of
the input but in general the thesis is
that in many cases album design can be
as hard as proving lower bounds okay we
just counter to this conventional view
the idea that designing a single
algorithm for solving the right kind of
problem would actually just yield a
lower bound for you so in fact there are
deep connections between the two Russell
will talk about the D randomization
connection but there's so deep that
often they are the same sometimes you
can set up equivalences but as mentioned
before some the equivalences are not so
nice like sometimes you need various
technical conditions to get in actual
equivalence okay
but the the kind of connection I want to
talk about sort of the most kind of
counterintuitive connection where the
design of an algorithm can lead to a
lower bound okay so like a typical
theory from our own design says here's
an algorithm a that solves my problem
all possible instance of the problem and
a typical theorem from lower balance
that here is a proof P then my problem
cannot be solved with all possible
Arbenz from some class okay what I want
to do is somehow draw an analogy between
the like the algorithm being designed
the algorithm a being designed and the
proof of the problem can't be solved
okay and analogy between all possible
instances of the problem in our case it
will be like a fixed computational
object like a circuit and and then now G
between that and all possible are in
some some class so this will be all
possible circuits from some class okay
okay so so more precisely okay well I
want to do this stuff to kind of the
following kind of quantifier match so
suppose I have a Turing machine okay and
it's there exists a Turing machine and
it's computing some non-trivial circuit
analysis problem it's solving some
problem like for example on all possible
circuits it's supposed to be a circuit
from some class maybe formula like it
will report whether it's satisfiable or
not for example that would be some
non-trivial circuit analysis the just
checking whether this circuit computes
the trivial function or not a function
which is all zeroes no okay okay so
suppose there exists such an algorithm
that does this for all circuits I want
to take that kind of statement and say
there exists a function f based on the
algorithm I design C such that for all
possible circuits this circuit cannot
compute this function in a very precise
sense so we will get circuit lower
bounds yeah that's also sort of talking
about it's sort of like a game that when
the algorithm succeeding in analyzing
the circuit sort of tantamount to the
circuit failing to compute the phone
so we'll have some connections of this
form yeah but it at least at a high
level
I hope the at least the kind of
quantifier match I want to do is clear
super high level okay so the outline of
these lectures will be its fall so in
this lecture I'll talk about circuit
analysis algorithms for meta algorithms
the over the next two lectures I'll talk
about circuit complexity just reviewing
basics and sort of complexity what's
known what isn't known connections
between these two topics circuit
analysis algorithms and circuit
complexity wind can't complexity imply
algorithms wind can't algorithms imply
lower bounds and the last lecture all
I'll give the proof of a particularly
lower bound that non-deterministic
exponential time doesn't have small
circuits from a particular class called
a sec okay alternating circuits with
counting the the main thing to think
about right now is in whatever those
acronyms mean is that the this sort of
question seemed out of reach until a few
years ago and really all that was needed
to prove such a result was just a look
at the look at what the lower boundary
problem required in the right way okay
so that's sort of what I want to
emphasize and talk and to talk about
different ways of looking at what is
required okay
to get a lower bound
okay so on to circuit analysis so
circuit analysis problems in general
they're computational problems that so
sometimes they're on circuits given as
input okay sometimes they're on truth
tables of functions we'll focus mostly
in this lecture on problems where the
circuit is given as input so your input
is a description of some logical circuit
let's say over Annan or not gates a fan
into generally speaking the particular
circuit basis won't matter
I will tell you exactly when it does
okay so that's the kind of input and the
output is some property of the function
computed by this circuit okay so this
circuit is taking some number of inputs
and output and I want to know some
property of that the truth table the
string of that function okay so the
canonical example of this is the circuit
satisfiability problem circuits at where
your input as a logical circuit see and
you want to decide is this function
compute is this basically the function
computed by this C all zeroes function
okay or does it have an assignment that
makes the circuit print one okay of
course as we know it simply complete but
we can still ask if there are algorithms
that solve circuits set that are faster
than the obvious brute-force algorithm
the algorithm which would try all 2d and
input settings to the in inputs the
circuit and just stick it in and
evaluate the circuit through you still
ask if there any algorithms solving this
problem faster than that okay we don't
because of it and because we don't think
it can be solved in time polynomial and
in and the size of the circuit but maybe
there's something something faster okay
Mohan talked about sat for more of a
case that problem we're gonna be talking
about that more broadly here
so we'll talk about I'm a generic
circuit satisfiability
so like that fancy see be a class of
boolean circuits so C could be boolean
formulas so circuits that look like
trees when you when you write them out
there's a dag they could be just
arbitrary circuits they could be CNF
formulas they could be casing their
formulas in which case we'd have the the
case that problem in general will have a
C set problem which says given a circuit
K from that class is there an assignment
to the inputs the inputs of the circuit
that makes it print 1 ok so you could
have you know case at which is for K CNF
formula set which is for formulas and so
on ok again this problem is essential is
np-complete for essentially all
interesting classes see and it's
solvable obviously using brute force
search try all possible assignments
evaluate them in time roughly linear in
the size of the circuit ok
all right and we want to know to what
extent this can be beaten and later
we'll look at when this can be beaten
what can you say about the circuit class
see ok so I mean there are two reasons
to think about solving this thing faster
what is just purely intellectual we have
a obvious silly algorithm for solving
the problem can you do something better
can you avoid being silly
ok even in the worst case that's one
motivation that motivated lots of people
ok people working on this long before I
was thinking about you but the new
motivation
another motivation alternative one is
that solve things like C set faster and
you get insight into what the the class
fancy C can compute you can you can
prove limitations I want for your class
can compute based on how well you can
solve this acceptable
okay so circuits at algorithms so if
we're simple enough circuits like kisi
Neffs this Mohan discuss we know of
algorithms faster than to Thea okay so
for example 3 set 1 mention is in 1.30 8
to the end it's randomized so you can
think of this right you can think about
3 sentences as a big and gate of ORS
with fan in 3 and these wires here point
to variables are their negations it sort
of rewriting what KC and if or 3-cnf
means here okay from for set you can't
get 1.3 to the end so every no but you
can't get something slightly faster and
4k set there's more on showed you can
give albums that run about 2 to the N
minus in over order K okay so this is by
many many many our authors and the three
set is from hardly recently and so the
the main observation I want to talk
about here is that all known faster than
to the end time alguns our case that
have the property that as K goes to
infinity this constant C and the base of
the exponent goes to two okay
in fact you like it seems you you get
this kind of behavior no matter what
algorithmic paradigm your use and that's
actually to me a very a very intriguing
phenomena like even getting like a log K
there we don't know how to do okay so
this led to the following hypotheses the
strong ETH which says that for all Delta
less than one so like the thing of Delta
is like 0.999 there exists some constant
K so that case that requires to to the
point nine nine nine in time okay
so essentially getting one point any
string of nines is just not possible
there is some constant K for which you
know the closet will be so large you
cannot even get one point that string of
nines to the entire so what it's saying
that you just can't improve
over this base of the exponent to as K
goes to infinity okay so that's so
Virginia talked about this and I want to
talk about this I won't talk it much
more about it okay and there's also the
ETH weird thing which just says just you
know solving 3sat requires to the Delta
in time for some Delta greater than zero
okay so you so there's 20 30 odd years
of work here and you're just never going
to have some infinite sequence of of
exponents getting closer and closer to 1
ok there's some constant out there maybe
one point one to the end you're just
never gonna solve 3sat better than that
that's does he teach ya and strong he H
does imply ETH okay so so far I haven't
heard arguments in these lectures
compelling arguments for sorry engage
but here's some compel so here's what I
would consider to be the most compelling
argument for story th because people
have heard me complain that I think star
engages false so let me play devil's
advocate just to show just to confuse
you okay so so this the main thing is
that this exponent is really remarkable
this kind of behavior like the best
analyses of backtracking algorithms we
know they get essentially this behavior
with a certain constant here the best
analyses of local search that we know is
the same Ralph's behavior may be a
different caution here okay
there are dynamic programming albums
which you would never run in practice or
a backtracking and local search they at
least have polynomial space dynamic
programming things will take exponential
space you can do all kinds of crossing
you still get that Timothy J and I
recently threw a lot of complexity
theory tools that trying to solve
orthogonal vectors in case that faster
turistica lee we have a new algorithm we
can actually count satisfying
assignments the case that it's very
radically different from any of these
things still has this behavior counting
but at least we can count
silence so there's something about
you're just getting beyond this kind of
behavior which which seems interesting
like the fact that it's shared by by you
know BACtrack images of totally
different classes having some local
search a total different class of
dynamic programming the stuff we use
like algebraic in nature all of them get
you this kind of thing when you're
optimizing so that that's sort of the
best reason I would think of but like
that actually says this is the right
answer there's something stronger than
join you so I'd be super strong ETH okay
you can quote me on that
okay in this video that's a super story
engage let's prove it false okay all
right okay it's not about that so so now
I'm going to differ a bit from what
mohan was talking about and talk about
more expressive circuit classes than
just Casey and F so you can think of
case C and FS right and of or of you
know fanon k of literals AC 0 is the
generalization of that where you allow
sort of arbitrary constant depth you
have or of an of ORS or or n or n stuff
like that
okay so just imagine having a constant
number of layers here but again with an
Oran not gates
okay so we have literals here on the
bottom variables and negations okay
so Russell Lowell Hardin and who in
Matthews showed that AC 0 set can in
fact be solved faster okay as the depth
increases so that's your constant depth
increases your saving gets worse and
worse but you still get some kind of
savings over to the end so you think of
- you know dividing the exhaustive
search by two to this amount it's
actually quite a lot if this is
something like polynomial this is like
an over poly log n so it's a pretty
substantial improvement okay but it's
not as good as what you get for say
depth to CNF set
okay alright so so there are even more
expressive circuit classes when I can
look at a very popular basis that people
look at for constant up circuses and or
not and a funny mod M gate so just think
of em as being some fixed integers at
least two and like for example mod six
it takes its inputs and just outputs one
if only if this sum is divisible by six
okay essentially this class arose from
the fact that mod two cannot be computed
in constant depth with an or not okay
this is a results proved by first Saxon
zipser and I type so people thought well
what if you just add that function in
for free into the basis well then you
can definitely compete them on two with
one gate what else what else can you do
okay so just you know throwing in this
divisibility check so it would look
something like this so again constant
number of layers but with mod sixes or
as an ant's okay and so something I
proved a while back is that actually
there's a faster set Algrim for this
class which is interesting because there
were no essentially no non-trivial lower
bounds known for this class yet you can
solve the sap problem faster so
essentially what this is saying is that
so you fix a depth D and fix one of
these modulus M okay now I'll give you a
circuit over mod M gates of that depth
and let's say it has sub-exponential
size so you think this may be a spot
like quasi-polynomial and if you don't
like little ones in your double exponent
quality pomian say so then you can solve
ACC 7 2 to the N minus in the e time
with this a depends is less than one
depends on this depth and modulus okay
but no matter what the depth and D is
the mod M are if they're constants then
you get some you divide brute-force
search by 2 to the end of the e e
all right so you can so having several
different aims is equivalent to taking
the product of those sims having a
single type of gate with the product of
isms so so for example it's known that
if M is a pond or a prime power then
there are very strong lower bounds No
namely for computing like mod like so if
it were mod P to the K for some prime P
take another prime a different prime Q
you can't compute at one Q okay but if
if I give you I would say mod 3 and mod
2 in your basis then that's equivalent
to having bought 6 actually that's too
hard to see there's a little but but
then the lower bound techniques known
for doing this just fail miserably name
namely because they the lower bound
techniques that did this use the which I
will talk about in a few moments
use the fact that if you have mod P
there then you can take any such circuit
and represent it and some approximate
sense by a low degree polynomial over a
field of characteristic P there's no
field of characteristic 6 and this makes
the the techniques very down for
monsters
anyone anymore Oh
all right so I will give you an overview
of how this set our rhythm goes because
it's it's quite different from the way
you would normally solve the case that
problem like that so it takes two
ingredients one is complexity theoretic
and one is entirely algorithmic the
first is a known representation of AGC
was known since the early 90s so if they
see said every function every boolean
function with the ATC circuit of size s
you can express in a very nice form you
can express it as a composition of two
simple functions G of H where H is a
multi linear polynomial with K monomers
means it doesn't have squares in it okay
it has some number K monomials where K
is quasi polynomial in s okay so you
think if s is being maybe polynomial
this is quasi-polynomial okay so it
doesn't have too many monomials doesn't
have 2 to the N monomials for example
and this and as I give you different 0 n
assignments to this polynomial it takes
on the value between 0 and K let's say
it's over the integers even its
coefficients are 0 and 1
well if I do that then then there if I
tell you that then this condition just
follows but yeah you can make it's
coefficient to 0 and 1
well yeah it's but it's evaluated over
the integers well you can even evaluate
mod capable of looking so you take that
and then then so you have this multi
linear polynomial with the smaller
monomials okay and then you have a
filter function which bait like G what
you busy takes something from this
larger domain and maps it down to 0 1 ok
you can write that as you just be
arbitrary you know and you can write
this as a lookup table what they proved
was much stronger than this but this is
the only thing we need but they proved
us actually we're stronger that in fact
this carnival could have low-degree poly
log s degree and that you can in fact
pick a specific function for the G's but
we don't we don't need any of that for
the other ok all right so that's the
complexity theoretic part and the
algorithmic part but fast we
transfer from multi linear polynomials
so given a multi linear polynomial H in
its coefficient representation so I give
you the value of all this coefficients
for all the two to the N possible
monomials there are no squares so
there's do the impossible and almost at
most then its value H of X can be
computed over all points in the boolean
hypercube so you want the end into the
end times poly n time
so if I give you like a really long
polynomial to the end coefficients just
naively evaluating it over all through
the endpoints would take to the N times
to the N time right for the N so somehow
you can make this linear in the
coefficient representation like if it
were if you happen to have two dating
coefficients okay so that's that's
basically the source of the speed up in
the cetera
okay so I'll talk a little bit about
these polynomials representing a cc I
won't be able to go to too much detail
about it but I hope give you a good idea
about about it yeah yeah yes it does yes
yes yes what's the running kind of it's
a quasi polynomial in that yeah
we're gonna set s where I remember s for
our us with sub-exponential like 2 to
the little o of 1 we're going to set the
look you know we're gonna make this
where he's put to the into little o of 1
here that's still to the end a little
one like this is I'm fixed polynomial in
the devil exponent that will get
absorbed in the low of 1 the double
exponent yeah maybe just me right there
so so if assets to the end of low of 1
this is also to the end to the low one
it so for any fixed polynomial there and
yeah and this thing can be constructed
official so yeah so how can we represent
a CC with these poems hey I was just
getting out of the way of the TV side
there's some very special cases so here
something like really really simple
cases how do you represent simple
functions using these G's of Ages so if
you want to write the or function as one
of these G's of Ages what do you need
you need like a multi linear polynomial
you need some filter function so you
could just take the sum of the bits as
you're milking your polynomial and let
your filter function G just be one if
and only if that sum is greater than 0
that will give double represent over for
sure and you take G composite age okay
and you can do and just as well just
make just make it so that you only have
at output one if if your input is in
okay so all these bits have to be one
double one I mean you know for any
symmetric function any function which
only depends on the number of inputs
which are one you can do this kind of
thing okay
by the ACC circuit is composition of a
bunch of these kinds of things
it's got it [ __ ] and hands and ma
Thames like all compose together so what
can we do we have to be a little more
sophisticated in this so so a less
special case is the following theorem of
for us ball offense Polanski
it's a bit of a mouthful but I'll say it
slowly so for every AC zero circuit C so
again constant depth and or an acht
circuit with cousin are layers has n
inputs size s and depth D so D layers
then there's efficiently sample
distribution so there's an algorithm D
randomized operon which takes C as input
it spits out a polynomial for you this
polynomial has low ich degree so if s
were polynomial and N and D is constant
this is like poly log degree over F to
the field of zero one so that the
following holds okay you give me a point
I want to evaluate the circuit C at this
point X then whenever I I run this
algorithm D on it once and you know draw
out a polynomial P the probability that
Paul Merrill P agrees with C is greater
than 3 over 4 okay so just drawing out a
random polynomial no matter what X I
have withdrawal random polynomial I get
agreement with probability at least 3/4
okay all right so this is a way of sort
of approximately representing a low
depth circuit with a very low degree
polynomial okay so in fact we can use a
small number s Epona so the sample space
here can be made quite small okay that
takes an argument but it can be made
quite small about into the poly log s
number of polynomials in total could
possibly be output by the sink okay so
the idea is that well once we have
explicit constructible set s of these
polynomials then or if you just take the
majority value of what the output over
all the different polynomials right that
would certainly tell us whether what the
value of P of X is because on a random
choice he agrees is probably greater
than 3/4 so if I take the majority of
everything then that's definitely gonna
give me the right answer okay all right
so
so I can write the majority so let me
just write down like what this is as a
circuit so there's a polynomial here but
it's really a circuit I mean it's really
a polynomial too so so you can always
think of a polynomial over f2
there's a big X or advance however each
of these ants is just a monomial and the
XOR is the sum over everything okay so
what we're wanting to do is so this is
like say a random draw from the
distribution and we're going to take the
majority over all these capital s
polynomials in the sample space
of all these different poems okay now
this thing will just give us the right
answer no randomness required we just
iterate over all around this in fact
with the smallest sample space this
majority of X or ands who give us the
right answer okay okay so we're not
quite there yet
because what we said was that you get
this you get this G of HS but so a key
observation here is that this G of H
thing can be seen as a circuit - okay so
right this thing is a multi linear
polynomial so we can think of it as a
summation over the integers of and gates
right and we we said it had not too many
monomials in it so it had some number K
monomials okay
then we had some filter function G right
which took the song and then gave us a
zero of one value
okay well all that's really doing is
just computing a symmetric function of
these ends so all this is really doing
it just giving you so this is H and this
is something that map's
0 1 2 K 0 1 so you had this whole thing
and some symmetric function so I write
that is sym sim of and gates
not even visible not easily visible well
I want to make it easy it's more visible
or just you know it's I mean it's more
visible and now it's more disgusting to
look at so well there's a trade-off I
guess yeah well that one ran out let's
see okay fine ooh jackpot
ooh someone's been over here today okay
uh-huh
okay sim of ants all right so we have a
majority of XOR vans we want to make it
look like this okay and so you can't
actually write a majority of X horse it
is a symmetric boolean function in fact
this is totally not obvious
there's Oh at least not obvious to me
starting with the work of Yahweh
actually was very key to totus theorem
that the Palmero hierarchy is contained
in P is a sharpie and it appears
obviously in this big ol Tori result
about a sec there's a way to take a
majority of X source and actually pack
the whole thing into one symmetric
function this it's pretty remarkable but
that's that's what's the idea about how
you just for misses you and for a cc
well it gets more complicated but and
there's like several different steps
that go in is the basic idea clear
let's see okay so far I've been in this
is now changed now I know that what what
the range to which I got number H maps
this is supposed to be a cake
did that help this K is quasi
appallingly on the circuit sighs let me
give a little more detail about this
rubber off Smolinski distribution
because yeah it's it's not too hard to
fit the whole thing on a slide and sort
of understand it but at the same time
it's very soul and people are still kind
of toying with it in and working out its
consequences so here's the theorem again
okay so I throw in a parity here that
just means I'm allowing mod to gates as
well so allow or and mod do and and not
okay you're gonna have an input size s
and FD and I want to get this
efficiently sample distribution with
this property so for every point X pick
a random opponent and distribution
probably agrees with the original
circuit is at least 3/4 so proof idea is
by induction on the depth D so in every
layer we're going to get a polynomial of
degree about log s okay that's randomly
representing the gates at that level
then we're just going to compose them
all there D layers of depth log s degree
in each one when we compose them all we
get log s the order D degree so the
composition of D log s degree
polynomials okay so not gate it's pretty
easy to do okay over f2 not gate 1 plus
thanks
right xor gate no sweat you never mod to
alright so the or gate is a tricky part
and we do it as false okay
so for every X there's a point zero one
at the end observe the following if I
take a random vector 0 1 vector now take
its inner product with the inputs x1 to
xn well probably that agrees with the or
is at least a half ok
just a random subset some principle ok
yeah so how many people have seen this
kind of argument before most everybody
ok ok so all right so so so we want to
do this in in amplify it so 1/2 is not
enough for us so we want to have a
probability of success which is you know
very large let's say 1 minus 1 over poly
s so that way for size this circuit if
we take a look at Union bound over all
the gates it will still work with high
probability
so do that to get a better no trade off
we do the following so instead of
picking one random vector we picked a
random vectors ok where K is some error
parameter so think of this is picking I
got a K by n random matrix all right so
for all 0 1 points where we're going to
form the following polynomial okay now
this polymer is of degree K so we're
taking a product over J goes 1 to K of
some sums we're adding 1 ok so I claim
that the probability this degree K
polynomial agrees with or on a given
point is at least 1 minus 1 over 2 to
the K now let's let's see what happens
ok suppose the or of this is 0 ok
suppose all the bits are 0 all right
so every one of these linear
combinations are going to be 0 right so
I add 1 they're all 1 the product of all
these 1
is one but I had another one so at zero
so that happens with probability one
okay so if if the or is zero if all
these bits are 0 then this polynomial
always evaluates a 0 over f2 okay now
now suppose it it happens to be one okay
so then each of each of these has a 1/2
chance of turning out to be 0 right
because this has a 1/2 chance of
agreeing with or when I add 1 with it
has a 1/2 chance of turning out to be 0
so I'm taking a product of K independent
things each of which has a 1/2 chance of
being 0 okay so so I have one only 1
over to the K probability of there all
right so this is a degree Kapaun
alternating or with air at most that
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
set K to be like 10 log s for example
okay then my air probability a
particular point is that most one over
polynomial in s it so if I Union bound
over all the ass gates still have great
chance of working
okay so I have degree order log S Paul
miles on each of these D layers when I
compose them all together to get a
single polynomial is gonna have this
degree here's my simple composition okay
any questions yeah in fact you can get D
minus 1 if you really want this yeah
yeah even even there's one slight proof
the bounders law gets the D yeah
yeah I mean I mean yeah try to find the
shortest proof you can of this statement
and we'll compare at the end if you get
bored have you sleep alright so so
that's the polynomials so now I want to
talk about the algorithmic part of the
algorithm okay so this is this fast
multi-point evaluation okay so I have
some multi linear polynomial and n
variables okay I give you this
coefficient vector then its value can be
computed in all points in the boolean
hypercube into the N times poly in time
okay this is actually a really we see
that really simple divide and conquer
okay given any multi linear polymer has
no squares at all you can always write
it as x1 times some polynomial in the
last n minus 1 variables plus some other
Pauling last n minus 1 variables just
separate the monomials that have x1 from
those are don't ok everything's
commutative no problem
all right so ok we want a table T that
contains the value of H and all to the
endpoints we can just recurse on h1 h2
okay that's this the whole album okay so
if n is equal to 1 if you've got one
variable then ok you just evaluate the
one variable twice 0 and 1 and you turn
that table otherwise you recursively
compute table t1 for the N minus 1
variable pawn or h1 you get U to the N
minus 1 linked table similarly for H 2
okay so then you're saying okay well
what do I want back well I want to say
just give me a table of through the n
entries so going to concatenate T to the
whole table 42 with a component wise
some of the table t1 plus t2 okay so
when x1 is 0 this term cancels and all n
H equals H 2 so that's x1 equals zero
part what x1 equals 1 it's just as h1
plus h2 so the component wise sum is
capturing that ok so I just return this
concatenated table no big deal all right
that's the algorithm listen
okay so the running time there's
occurence okay I want to take a little
slice to the end I do two recursive
calls get to the N minus one and I do
some extra stuff to like sort the
monomials say component-wise add to the
intense paulien most and so this
recurrence just solve the to the end
times boolean as well for a slightly
bigger poly right yes sir
so using this you can compute the G of H
you know for any G looks like this zero
one of the k201 any multilinear upon oil
h on all possible assignments and only
to the incomes poly n time okay so this
algorithm definitely tells you how to
how to get all the values of H all the
outputs of age then they get to the
outputs of G you can just do some simple
sorting to do all right so so using this
you can evaluate one of these symma pans
or G of HS on all possible points very
efficiently even if this thing happens
to be big like to to the end to the
little o of one size okay in fact the
way it's written here this thing could
just be even to the N to the N size so
now I'll present the set algorithm okay
so the theorem is for all depths D and
moduli m there's an epsilon sort of a CC
set with so a CCM just means it's got
mod M gates in it with depth D and
inputs and to the epsilon size can you
solve an 2 to the N minus Omega epsilon
time okay so so this you know definitely
gives us the the theorem if it has some
exponential size okay in to the end a
little of one all right so we start with
a circuit see this got to the end the
epsilon size and n inputs all right
so the first thing we do it's a little
strange when you first see it but
eventually just becomes natural is to do
a mild brute force inside the circuit so
let the circuit itself simulate a mild
brutal
so what we do is for example take the
first into the epsilon inputs to the
circuit try all possible to the in the
epsilon values for it okay
and take the or of all the circuits you
get from plugging in these different
into the epsilon bit assignments okay so
I'm just taking the first into the
epsilon in plus trying all possible
assignments to them for each one I get a
different sub circuit okay now just take
the or of all that okay so I've blown up
the size of the circuit by some amount
some quadratic amount but the number of
inputs has gone down okay so it's sort
of a size input trade-off okay but so
there's sort of two important things a
note here if C is an ACC circuit of
depth D then this say C prime is the AC
circuit of depth D plus one
yeah I just added an extra order the
second thing is this C is satisfiable if
and only if this C prime is satisfiable
okay so if this has a satisfying
assignment there's some way to set the
epsilon and make this thing pret one on
something here there's some sub circuit
accumulating exactly that and it will
print one here on okay okay
so we preserve satisfiability by doing
this trick so then we run this beagle
under Tory this is G of H decomposition
on this circuit okay so get a g of HS
and so what this does is it writes oh it
blows us up by a quasi-polynomial okay
but quasi-polynomial and this translates
the two to the end of the order epsilon
up here
yeah so if you've got again as I erase
it
all right so get this gif of HS here
which we can also write as a sim of ants
thing and now we just use this FFT
algorithm that we had okay on this thing
but the key points that this has a
smaller number of inputs in before so
when we evaluate this thing on all
possible inputs we actually have
something running faster than to the end
okay so we can evaluate this object on
all of its possible inputs and
polynomial amortize time per assignment
so we base so if this has got K inputs
we can get to the K times polygon and so
we end up doing is getting a valuation
that runs in to the N minus in the
epsilon times polygon and so once we've
evaluated this G of H on all that's
possible assignments right we just need
to check if any of if it ever printed
one or if it ever prints one and you
know it satisfy both to always print
zero
all right then this thing is
unsatisfiable so this thing is
unsatisfiable and therefore this thing
is in satisfied we just check checking
this thing every prints woman okay so
this is a very different paradigm from
backtracking local search the other
things tour I mentioned yesterday and
but yeah but it's still you know giving
you something for some circuit class
that we had no idea what to do we had
some we had some complexity theory way
of expressing it with multi linear
polynomials we didn't know what to do
inside out and gives you away to reason
so so for example we can so starting
from ATC you can take more expressive
circuit classes like formulas at so if
it did Morgan formulas at where you got
formulas over an or not in each gate is
Fanning it most to its known that you
can get faster Sat algorithms for
formula set but only for formulas of
size up to roughly and cubed which is
interesting because this is exactly the
the strongest lower bound size that we
know for D Morgan formulas as well and
this is not really there's not really a
coincidence okay there there is a there
is a good explanation for that like
basically the same kind of ideas which
get you limitations on formulas up to
cubic size also allow you to get really
fast
branching algorithms for forums up to
that size okay
and for formulas over let's say an or
not an X or with fan into I can also get
the formulas an hour and faster again up
up to this not cubic but quadratic size
and that's again exactly the place where
the techniques to lower bound techniques
no longer apply we don't know how to get
super quadratic lower bounds there and
for let's say generic circuits at over
an or not with fan into I think a big
open problem is can we improve over
exhaustive search can we improve over to
the N times s time Thank You me oops I
think I accidentally just into the
presentation oh yeah so can we give me
to do anything better than exhaustive
search here where is it come from so you
can put like three - like Lulu one
roughly here I mean like yeah I mean
it's essentially three and this is
essentially - yeah but that's all I
wanted to convey yeah
yes yeah oh I thought you wanted me to
explain the lower bail but wait that's
another time okay
okay yeah I can do that too all right so
okay so that's enough about a circuit
set okay so I want to speak briefly
about a problem that Russell mentioned
and just sort of talk about in a survey
style so but this is not just for like
generic circuits as Russell's been doing
but like different circuit classes you
can talk about the same kind of thing so
if you let fancy T be some class of
boolean circuits define some circuit
approximation probability problem for it
which is given a circuit kay we want to
output a value V so that it closely
approximates the probability that on a
random assignment the circuit accepts
okay we're just approximating the
probability the circuit accepts okay
and this one over ten you know you can
it's just some arbitrary it's an
arbitrary thing you can as usual in
these randomized things you can modify
this this constant okay so we want to
solve this problem deterministically
okay solving it with randomness is very
easy just randomly sample inputs and see
what happens so as Russell's been
mentioning is related to pseudo-random
generators into your animation very
intimately linked so I won't say much
more about that I do want to talk about
like the progress that has been made on
restricted circuit classes for this okay
and it's interesting a note that the
progress we made here so the the running
time Aven through here are much better
than the algorithms for set okay and
there and there's a reason for this and
we actually believe everything on the
slide is solvable in polynomial time
okay we believe P equals B VP so this
problem should be solved when pawn will
time deterministically so everything
here should be plumbing time but this is
what the progress we have so far okay
all right so you can't say that about a
second side I guess all right so for AC
zero circuits if you want to approximate
the probability the thing except you can
do it in n time quasi-polynomial in the
circuit size okay but you can't have
some sort of your exponential factor
in the depth so I mean it's worth
comparing these two things so so I had
like log floor asks for this and for
force at I had something like that's
something like this so this is for sat
and this is my cap for ACC right so
quasi-polynomial versus slightly better
than to you
okay so for CNF the cat problem is an
almost polynomial time so the closest
problem I know that being palma that
isn't actually polynomial
yeah maybe maybe i'm not do you know do
you know something you know with a lower
exponent than this yeah so yeah so it's
almost certainly in power on time and
probably doable what do you think okay
anyway so into the log log n time okay
if you've got st. pauli n closets okay
so this is you know stark contrast from
like us the CNF sat we're just trying to
be you know to the end I get 1.9 is a
yes yes apollyon number of clauses yeah
yeah now as we increase the complexity
of the circuit this is you know the
boundary nor worse and worse so for
DeMorgan formula cap so this is an or
not know X source you can get into the
two to the end of the e time so this is
e being some a less than one per formula
size up to cubic okay recall we were
percent we're taking to the N minus into
the e so this is still very nice you
know getting that for sat would be
amazing this is what we get for for
approximating the puzzle okay and then
for general formula cap again we can do
this up right up to the best circuit
bluebells and these of all use different
techniques and lower bounds alright so
yeah again we we think that all these
are solved with terminus of the Implanon
time okay and solving them faster does
give us some insight into the function
being impeded by the circuit some
circuit analysis problem yeah
yes frequency oh it's this uniform
just-just-just yeah flip each bit of the
input probably have yeah it's just it's
no different from like yet like the
computing than the number or
approximating the number the fraction
yeah gonna confident yeah yeah
so so I want to talk a little bit about
other circuit analysis problems not just
ones that take circuits as input so
certain apps web can also analyze
functions directly so the canonical
example this is the minimum circuit size
problem which is been studied for a very
long time so here the input is a to the
N bit truth table of a boolean function
so I'll give you like the value of the
function on all possible inputs and I
give you some parameter s and what I
want to know is is the minimum size of a
circuit computing this function at most
s okay so I give you the function now I
want to know something about its circuit
complexity there's a minimum size at
most s this is a decision version of it
you could imagine taking the truth table
I was trying to compute what is the Cir
complexity of it okay over N or not fan
in T so it's important to note that this
problem actually is an NP okay because I
give you the whole truth table the input
is a link to the end so you know the
maximum size of circuit can be of the
circuit complexity is you know it most
about to the end over in in fact and so
you could just guess that circuit then
just evaluate all possible inputs and
check whether the input is of link to
the end so this is poly to the end no
problem okay so this is an NP problem
okay
and it's why they conjectured this
problem is not contained in polynomial
time if it were in real time we could
break any pseudo-random function
candidates for example like so any any
circuit that's trying to pretend it's a
random function would not be you know
using our powerful upon all time
algorithm we could just compute this
sort of complexity of what is giving us
and supposedly suitor Graham bits okay
now it's known in terms of hardness it
is known that if I want to find the
minimum size of a DNF computing this
function that is np-complete okay so now
you know we understand DNF really well
compared to like circuit complexity in
general this uses lower bounds on DNF
actually to get so a bigger problem is
whether this problem is actually MP
complete and recently with my student
cody Murray we've made some some
progress on this question we've shown
that if it isn't be complete then it
would imply it has to require techniques
that they're just you know not not like
any other polynomial time reduction
we've ever seen so so what we show is
that if mcsp is np-complete under poly
time reductions then X was different
from Z P P so we get some result of the
form you know that Russell was lamenting
about we don't know how to prove ok
just from a poorer time reduction
showing this thing is Impe hard we
wouldn't have a separation we were
people to show Graham this is not
super-powerful you still don't know so
so if it is and be complete it would it
would have to have some consequence no
Paul no time reduction I've ever seen
could you know do so has to be radically
weird and we show that for more
restrictive reductions in polynomial
time you can actually rule out that just
simply is not np-complete under more
restrictive reductions
reductions okay I can be more specific
poly log time projections so we're each
bit of the reduction can be computed in
poly logarithmic time yeah we can we can
improve that just simply not and be
completing are these reductions okay I'm
running low on time so but I think I'm
towards the end so open problem is to
find any improvement over exhaustive
search for this problem just anything
better than just trying all possible
circuits besides us and seeing what
happens okay so I'm almost done
so what's known to be an np-hard
oh oh is it a good candidate for a
problem that's not gonna be and be hard
but but could require whatever the
exhaustive search yeah I think this is a
really good candidate for a problem like
that
but it probably isn't be hard you're
just gonna require you know
understanding the power of randomness
first that's my opinion I mean I don't I
don't I mean you could think of
different ways you could say oh you know
Paula note our induction shouldn't imply
that so it is unlikely I think it just
means that we're gonna have to learn a
lot more about circuits and ran this
before we can yeah could be could be
just hard it could just be it could just
be simply not solvable in polynomial
time but not expressive enough to be
np-hard
that could be true too I don't think so
I don't think I know anything off the
top of my head I mean at the same time I
wouldn't consider that unlikely so yeah
yeah but it's just wait yeah it's really
unpleasant did you have a question
like it's deterministic yeah they're
deterministic mini one reductions yeah
you think that what about reductions
like a non-uniform non-uniform
reductions that's a very interesting
question yeah we we don't know there is
a results for that but if we look at pi
log time projections even randomized by
a long time rejection even like
algorithms which reads like up to like a
cube root of n bits of input and then
output a bit even if they're randomized
we can show they don't exist so I guess
this is basically saying that any
reduction you know even even from the
parity problem to mcsp you can show such
a reduction or business so like any
reduction showing a hardness of mcsp for
practically anything is gonna have to be
very non-local sort of makes sense I
mean because of this you're supposed to
be printing something that's hard
circumplex see if it were local didn't
should have up maybe smaller
representation
well I'm cooking I see things happening
but
okay so a couple more things I wanted to
mention was that there's been a lot of
results about showing the power of
circuit minimization so showing that it
it can do things that we don't think can
be solved for example factoring integer
factorization can be done in randomized
: I'm with an Oracle for circuit min the
discrete logarithm problem similar can
be solved and will be be slightly
different version of randomized time and
even graph isomorphism can be solved
using an Oracle for circuit min so these
are some pretty remarkable results Erik
Allender is the a on all these things
been leading the charge on them so some
open problems about this is I like to
find some interesting problems in P with
an Oracle for mcsp because right here
these are random these are sort of
randomized Turing reductions in a in a
sense right like showing that that with
roundness in US and being able to
compute circumplex so you can do all
kinds of interesting things what if you
don't have ran this at all so here's
another thing so if I give you the truth
table now if a circuit I want to know
it's ER complexity I don't know how to
produce the minimum size circuit from
that I can only tell you whether or not
the the truth table I'm given is easy or
hard
so can you can you get some sort of self
reducibility can you produce a circuit
given a truth table Oracle another
question is how hard is this thing for
AC zero circuits okay so we know it's
it's MP hard for DNS is it so you know
but we know that like we have
exponential lower bounds on DNS we don't
have like truly expensive little grounds
on H zero so maybe we can prove some
kind of harness for quasi MP you know
not intercede quasi polymer so all these
different arms of circuits is just one
tiny part of this area of the exact
talents or np-hard problems which will
see it a lot about this semester lots of
cool open problems a few of them mention
here and here's the outlines of the rest
of lectures again their complexity
connections next one these
sorry for taking up Oh like the so this
is sort of like the compression problem
yeah that Valentin's been looking at Oh
within PETA mcsp I haven't thought about
that problem at all yeah so trying to
print like some circuit that's not like
a minimum size but just like
approximately I haven't thought of this
film at all it sounds like a good
problem yeah I have an organizational
question is there still somebody who
feels responsible for ensuring that all
the open questions from the tolls we
eventually find their way to the
Yokohama water yes that would be nice
yeah exactly this the open protein
coordinators still coordinating yeah
he's corny I think my probably happen
like early next week but it will happen
at some point
so so in a longer version of this talk
and so not only talk more about cap but
also but also this this question of
compression so you're given a truth
table and of us some function and your
promise it has the circuit when it has a
circuit of you know reasonably small
size you can output some non-trivial
circuit for it all right like something
like weaker than mcsp yeah so I mean
obviously that's useful mm-hmm I mean in
terms of other other problems I mean not
really this is sort of the constellation
of problems of people so oh but that's
for algebraic complexity I mean that's a
totally different talk and well actually
Russell's giving that talk isn't he
thank you testing Oh checking whether
Coulomb yeah but this is more or less at
I mean with a different extra gate at
the top
was that you can get a lot yeah